because like i know sydney her her
downtime thing is that she watches
horror movies and
i don't know
how she finds so many [ __ ] horror
movies to watch i didn't know this many
horror movies existed she watches at
least three new horror movies every week
dude at least the the the cesspool of
horror movies is like never ending it's
actually insane like because i was never
i'm like i was never big into horror
movies i don't really like horror movies
um
and i assume you guys aren't big fans
either because none of it showed up on
our three by threes no i don't like not
a single one there's some there's some
good ones but it's it's like it's not my
favorite genre yeah yeah
um but she somehow finds so many shots
huh shining's really good shauni's good
i i like the shine i like there's only a
few horror movies i really like
shining's one of them i've really
because like my my taste in horror
movies is really niche i think because i
like kind of loved craftian horrors
because i don't like the usual like you
know jump scares ghost paranormal stuff
what's the problem is that so much
horrors jump scares now yeah it is it is
cheap and easy to rely on yeah that's i
think that's why i'm such a big fan of
like jinji uto and stuff like that
because it's really like the horror that
i like is really just the ones that
really unsettle me like the carb horror
yeah yeah yeah yeah no i'm exactly like
that like the kind of like asian horror
is like definitely
more my taste in horror because yeah
again it's like you see like you know
you watch one paranormal activity you've
basically seen them all how the [ __ ] did
paranormal activity get so big it's
because steven spielberg green led it he
literally is that true yeah so i i
actually read up on it because i had the
exact same thought i was like i saw
[ __ ] the trail of a paranormal
activity 73 and i was like how yeah why
are there so many but i remember when it
when it came out i was in school and
ever everyone was like this is the
scariest movie ever yeah so scary yeah i
know right and i was just everyone was
like [ __ ] their pants over it i
remember because i was in university at
the time and so i was like all right
i'll see what the hype's about because
uh back then my roommates had a watch
party and then we watched uh paranormal
activity the first one and i
everything everyone was like jumping at
just like the [ __ ] closet opening and
i'm just like i can literally see the
[ __ ] string being used to open this
[ __ ] door how is this scary what is
going on
one remote press
one i thought wasn't bad was it the
invisible men it wasn't that bad
actually is that what it's called oh the
invisible man the one about
i like um i watched the other day i
finally watched um what is it hereditary
oh oh how was that one because because i
missed out on it when it first came out
so i i kind of missed the initial hype
because i was like western hearts
whatever for me yeah but then i think
felix showed me midsummer which is done
by the same guy arias yeah yeah and i
was like okay this is very creepy but
also kind of cool and experimental so i
was like all right well i heard
hereditary was pretty good i watched it
it's uh
it's weird i don't i wouldn't i almost
wouldn't even call it a horror film it's
like
i don't know it's you know what it feels
like it feels like if david lynch made a
horror film yeah you know okay where
it's like it's it's scary but it's also
as we established in the previous 3x3
joey the big arts knob yeah david lynch
i feel like you just to make a good
horror movie you have to be [ __ ] up
yeah well yeah
you'll just be completely [ __ ] up to
make any horror content i feel you need
to be [ __ ] up maybe in some aspects
actually uh me and sydney watched uh we
we had uh we had a night the other day
that we just kind of like binged part of
like the final destination series
and
the reason for that was because i kind
of i kind of remembered my very first as
a teenager i loved those films yeah yeah
i remember the very first time i watched
final destination and was it was
actually in school right right um so i
think it was like i think it was like
middle school at the time so i was like
i think around 12 13 years old and i
don't know if the same thing for
australia but you know like at the end
of term in school right it's kind of
like a free frog and the teachers it's
kind of like that period where it's like
the last two classes of the year or
something teachers just let you let you
do whatever the [ __ ] you want right yeah
was that true in australia yeah i
definitely it depends on the school but
yeah yeah i think most schools it was
kind of just like i'm going on break in
[ __ ] three days yeah whatever yeah so
it was just like it's just like in the
school that was in you just had a week
period where you just basically
basically go to class and every teacher
would put on a different film or just
like roll in the team yeah just roll
just roll on the tv and everyone will
watch a different film and like [ __ ]
90 percent of the time it was shrek it
was fun
it was just awesome
we watch shrek like every year yeah okay
good good to know that that was just a
nationwide it's that time of year okay
it's like end of year all right i guess
it's shrek again and like i remember
this one class um one of one of my
classmates brought in a dvd yeah right
because
we were just
because the teacher would ask what does
everyone want to watch and so this guy
samuel
he he brings out the dvd and he brings
out final destination and he was like
this is this is a film i think the
entire class would want to watch and
everyone's like yeah sure anything
i think we were like 12 at the time
i had not heard a final destination at
the time but we're like yeah sure like
because like you know anything to get us
away from shrek or whatever or whatever
whatever the usual films were watching
right so he was like miss this i i think
that the classroom would watch would
want to watch this and nobody kind of
like opposed it so and the teacher had
never heard of the film before okay so
she was like dangerous so she was like
this boy just had this dvd on him i i
think he knew what he was doing right
yeah and so um so the film starts off in
final destination and characters are
always like it's it's i don't know what
the rating was like back then
but characters were
already swearing but
i think in pg films in like the uk even
if you have like one or two swear words
it can still be skewered towards like
the lower ratings if it's just like one
or two swear words
yeah um so like characters so i remember
the opening scene where they like get on
the plane and people start arguing or
whatever um it's it's kind of sus
because you can hear people obviously
swearing
and the teacher's just like uh samuel is
this
is is this suitable for this adrian is
like yeah miss don't worry it's just the
opening scene don't worry miss like just
don't worry about it and she's like okay
okay and so i remember the opening scene
is where like i i think it's it's where
the plane crashes that's the first final
destination i remember
[Music]
so
uh so a bunch of 12 year olds just
watching
uh watching this plane take off and then
obviously um the plane starts to crash
uh the the wing snaps and everyone's
[ __ ] screaming it's terrifying right
in the scene and then you see like blood
splatter and then you see someone
getting burned alive
and
immediate
immediately like the [ __ ] the teacher
gets up aggressively like aggressively
gets off to the tv doesn't even doesn't
even switch it up unplugs the tv and
goes
samuel
get outside now
and
that was my very first experience at
final destination absolutely chad samuel
he was like he probably walked out i was
like worth it